Kim kardashian-west is a mom a reality
star a business mogul and now the
inspiration for some higher education
core Darrell McMurray
as a young man who has gone viral after
writing his master's degree thesis all
about Kim K he tweeted at her and uh
wait for it she tweeted him back saying
I want a copy joining me now is the
author himself Cordero thank you so much
for being here
Cordero yeah and what a moment so
you'reyou're just graduated with your
master's degree from Arizona's Northern
Arizona University and so you had to
write a thesis to get your master's in
communication and Media Studies what
made you want to write it on Miss Kim
Kardashian and Tom tell me quickly like
what your thesis is well I decided to
write about Kim Kardashian west because
she is a you know a viral person she
knows how to break the internet so back
in October of 2016
she had the tragic event of being robbed
in Paris and at that time we all know it
was a big political stance here in
America for Americans because we had the
2016 presidential debates
so that was breaking news that was
everywhere covered throughout social
media and regular news platforms at that
time when Kim was robbed they both were
breaking news and I asked myself how are
they both breaking news and reading the
comments and surfing through the web a
lot of people were just like who cares
about Kim like we need to focus on this
political time and end period so that
right there was the click in my head
well then why don't I just you know
analyze that
so I analyzed her being robbed it's all
positive and I kind of just looked at
you know why did news stations cover
Kim's robbery and is that news does
social media change the way we seek news
content nowadays well I think the answer
is yes and I'm excited to see how you
Dovan to it though you tweeted after
taking an extra year
see eight pages long nights and early
mornings I finally graduated with my
master's degree and then
k'kaw herself responds after you tagged
her and she says that she wants a copy
and you said I have to get you a copy of
the thesis focuses on you so my question
is how are you gonna get her a copy of
you and Kim like DMD cuz yeah a couple
days later she after you tweeted that
she said I want a copy for myself what's
the next step the next step I'm just
waiting for her to either follow me back
or have someone from her team reach out
so we can set that up I'd love to give
her a copy it's literally right here
ready for her package ready to go what
is that do you have a title or a
headline on your thesis what is it yes
so the title is a New Age of broadcast
news popular culture social media and
the transformation of broadcast news I
love it well Kim kardashian-west has
certainly transformed social media women
in business so many things an icon I
truly feel so I applaud you on the
selection of your master's thesis here
how did your professors respond to your
thesis being about Kim they cut you know
they kind of laughed and they said you
know go for it do what you want to do
because it's going to show and so I said
easy so I you know long days and long
nights I I stayed up kinda had to do a
lot of research change a lot of things
because you know two years ago social
media and Twitter has changed its VAM so
much so I had to keep going back and
change right everything's changing as
you're trying to write your thesis I
have done a master's paper myself and I
ran it I did it on celebrity news and
ran into the same issue so I applaud you
congratulations to you and I love that
Kim gave you a shout out let us know if
you're able to you know DM with her and
get her the copy of the thesis cuz we
would love to hear about it
congratulations cordero yes thank you
guys so much thank you
[Music]
[Applause]